[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi 5 septembre
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 78 les
titres de cette édition la rentrée
parlementaire approche elle est fixée au
25 septembre à l'assemblée nationale
une première pour onze députés de la
république en marche des yvelines notre
invité est l'un d'entre eux didier
baichère député de la première
circonscription du département
c'est une solution pour les jeunes sans
formation l'école de la deuxième chance
des yvelines propose un accompagnement
individualisé pour se remettre sur le
chemin de la réussite professionnelle
100 places sont disponibles en septembre
nous en parlons avec hervé de marc
directeur de l'établissement et qu'à la
fin de ce journal direction la ville de
maurepas une jeune maman crève l'écran
elle a récemment participé à une
émission sur la chaîne m6 pour ses
talents de couturière
avant de débuter
quinze mille euros damende sentence
requise contre deux militants de l214
l'association de défense animale
hier il était jugé au tribunal
correctionnel de versailles pour s'être
introduit clandestinement dans
l'abattoir guillard ont deux ou dans les
deux personnes qui ont reconnu les faits
avait posé à des caméras les images
filmées montraient la mise à mort
violente des ports
le jugement sera rendu par le tribunal
de versailles le 9 octobre prochain
25 pompiers des yvelines ont pris la
route ce matin du sud de la france ils
sont envoyés en renfort pour la lutte
contre les incendies qui touchent en ce
moment le département des bouches du
rhône engagements prévus jusqu'à ce
week-end et qui peut s'étendre à dix
jours maximum
en tout c'est un contingent de 100
soldats du feu qui s'en s'ont delà du
feu franciliens pardon qui est partis
prêter main forte dans le sud
ce n'est pas une mais des rentrées que
propose l'école de la deuxième chance
est des yvelines toute l'année notamment
sur son site de trappes 100 places sont
par exemple disponibles en septembre
l'établissement offre aux 18 25 ans en
formation la possibilité de bénéficier
d'un accompagnement individus
lisez et d'envisager ainsi leur avenir
professionnel plus sereinement et des
images de michael elle n'est d'euros
quand je suis arrivé ici j'étais
vraiment très timide et grâce à grâce à
leur deuxième chance je suis seule
ouverte
ils sont beaucoup chaque année dans le
même cas kim anh des jeunes parfois
perdus ou en échec scolaire l'école de
la deuxième chance leur donne l'occasion
de prendre un nouveau départ et des
rentrées ont lieu tous les mois et le
parcours au sein de l'établissement se
fait de manière personnalisée ce qui
permet de trouver rapidement une
solution pour l'avenir de l'élève et
volkl bonheur des du gène ça veut dire
trouver un métier sortir avec avec une
formation avec un travail en tout cas
sortir avec un truc qui est positif à
l'école de la deuxième chance les jeunes
alternent entre deux semaines de cours
et deux semaines de stage dans le milieu
professionnel
il bénéficie d'une rémunération
mensuelle et de la gratuité dans les
transports franciliens au sein de
l'établissement les élèves sont épaulés
sur les savoirs fondamentaux français
maths ou encore bureautique et sont
accompagnés individuellement par un
formateur référent qui les soutient dans
toutes leurs démarches
une petit bonheur c'est de voir
justement que tout d'un coup ils sont
capables de trouver par eux mêmes
devoirs que tout d'un coup ils sont
capables de comprendre qu'effectivement
non ils sont pas plus nul que les autres
au contraire quoi c'est juste le système
qui est peut-être les a écrasés d'une
façon ou d'une autre je n'en sais rien
mais en tout cas j'ai j'aime bien les
voir grandir et se rendre compte de ce
que de leur valeur l'établissement est
présent sur trois sites dans le
département attrape les mureaux et
magnanville chaque année plus de 400
jeunes passent par les rangs de l'école
de la deuxième chance des yvelines et
pour réagir sur ce sujet et parler de
l'école de la deuxième chance nous
recevons sur ce plateau hervé de marque
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
de l'école de la deuxième chance des
yvelines alors pour débuter ce cette
interview une petite réaction sur le
sujet les deux élèves que l'on a
interrogé insistait sur une chose elles
ont pris confiance en
grâce à à l'école de la deuxième chance
des yvelines c'est aussi ça la mission
de l'établissement s'est redonné
confiance
faire prendre conscience finalement aux
jeunes de ses capacités c'est surtout ça
et effectivement je suis épaté tellement
les en parle bien mais je les pattes et
à chaque fois mais c'est des jeunes qui
ont souvent été un petit peu abîmés par
leurs débuts d'histoires de vie en
moyenne ils ont 20 ans et effectivement
le l'ingrédient essentiel c'est que
c'est d'être capable de restaurer la
confiance qu'ils peuvent avoir en eux
parfois il était sur le point de
renoncer d'avoir trop intégré le fait
qu'ils étaient en difficulté et et
qu'ils avaient une large part de
responsabilité même si nous on a
toujours un peu à chaque fois mes mails
à cesser de prendre cette belle citation
de proust qui dit qu' il n'y a jamais de
réussite facile mais qui a jamais
déconvenue définitive et on est vraiment
là dessus sur la confiance on va parler
justement du contenu de cette formation
à l'école de la deuxième chance le
principe ça a été aussi rappelé dans le
reportage c'est qu'il n'ya pas une mais
des rentrées qui se déroule en fait
chaque mois
c'est ça c'est exactement ça on est sur
un système d'entrée et de sortie
quasiment permanente
par contre c'est la période de l'année
où on a le plus de places disponibles
parce qu'on a beaucoup de jeunes qui
sortent pendant la période estivale soit
parce qu'ils trouvent un emploi soit
parce qu'ils réintègrent une formation
qualifiante contrat d'apprentissage ou
quelque chose comme ça donc là on a
beaucoup de place en ce moment donc 100
places disponibles dès septembre pour 7
rentré de vraiment en capacité
d'accueillir de nombreux jeunes et on
est très content de pouvoir venir le
dire ici pour que tout le monde
l'entende
et donc c'est 100 places s'est réparti
sur les trois sites à trappes
magnanville aux mureaux oui
effectivement on a une école à saint
quentin en yvelines celle de trappes end
sur le bassin d'emploi des mureaux et
une autre sur le mantois pour qu'on
pouvoir couvrir le maximum de besoins
dans le département et puis c'est aussi
un réseau national avec plus d'une
centaine d'écoles comme ça sur toute la
france
alors concrètement comment ça comment ça
se passe au sein de l'établissement de
l'entrée du jeune son passage et à la
sortie qu'est ce qu'il va pouvoir avoir
bénéficié sur place déjà on peut parler
d'eux un petit peu avant l'entrée et il
faut savoir que l'on peut candidater à
l'école de la deuxième chance sous
réserve qu'on est entre 18 et 25 ans et
on réfléchit à pouvoir accueillir des
jeunes un peu plus jeune et qu'on soit
sans diplôme ni qualification c'est ça
notre coeur de métier
et puis après il ya un ingrédient
essentiel et c'est avec celui ci que le
jeune doit venir c est l avoir envie de
construire son projet professionnel et
après ben on peut l'objectif de ça c'est
de faire le point sur ce qu'on sait
faire
parce que souvent on sait déjà faire
beaucoup de choses même si c'est parfois
pas toujours très bien rangé
c'est bien aussi d'avoir en tête ce dont
on est capable de faire voilà c'était
souvent il faut le découvrir ce dont il
est capable de faire et c'est la
confiance c'est ça c'est ça et est donc
le but c'est d'accéder soit un premier
métier et nous on aime bien dire choisi
derrière puisque c'est important de
pouvoir choisir le métier qu'ils
exercent
et puis ça peut être aussi une formation
qualifiante parce que c'est important de
pouvoir se qualifier et souvent on a un
meilleur projet professionnel et un
meilleur avenir comme adultes si on a
une qualification
vous l'avez dit le but à réussir à
atteindre ce premier métier choisi
chaque année on l'a dit 400 jeunes
passent par par les rangs de l'école de
la deuxième chance est ce que vous avez
une idée du taux de réussite finalement
nombre de jeunes qui tous qu'ils
trouvent une formation à l'issue de ce
passage à l'école de la deuxième chance
ou qu'ils trouvent un métier tout
simplement l'on mesure ça de très près
et puis on a des financeurs aussi qui
sont très intéressés et fort
heureusement parce à ces résultats il
faut il faut les comprendre en deux
temps d'abord on a une période d'essai
pour savoir si on est capable de
travailler ensemble et il ya 85 % des
jeunes qui réussissent cette période
d'essai et puis parfois des fois il faut
revenir où on est on est pas encore tout
à fait prêt et sur ces 85 % de jeunes
qui réussissent la période d'essai sur
l'ensemble du parcours et sur
l'accompagnement qu'on leur propose à
l'issue de ce parcours ce que s'inscrire
dans un projet professionnel ça se passe
aussi dans les entreprises on a 75 % de
réussite
l'année dernière qui est une année
exceptionnelle on fait pas toujours
d'aussi bons résultats mais on n'a
jamais fait
moins de 60 % de sorties positives comme
on dit donc c'est un concept qui marche
très très bien mais c'est aussi parce
que les jeunes il consacre une très
grande énergie alors dernière chose
comment tout simplement intègre ton
cette école de la deuxième chance
et bien tout simplement il faut prendre
contact avec l'école soit directement
par téléphone il ya même des jeunes qui
viennent nous voir physiquement et et
puis il ya aussi notre page facebook ou
le site internet de l'école où il ya un
petit formulaire d'inscription
donc il ya plein de moyens possibles et
ils sont tous très bons
d'ailleurs le sit ins affiche pour nos
téléspectateurs
il ya aussi parlent par émission locale
aussi on peut on alors après les
conseillers missions locales peuvent
prescrire bien évidemment et on
travaille très très bien avec l'ensemble
des missions locales du département
merci relais de marc et d'avoir été avec
no mercy de mercredi je rappelle
directeur de l'école de la deuxième
chance des yvelines elle rythme chaque
rentrée et fait parfois des déçus la
nouvelle carte scolaire des yvelines a
été dévoilée après les derniers jugent
ajustement de l'académie de versailles
et 21 ouvertures de classes notamment
aux écoles élémentaires à louise weiss à
magny les hameaux et grande île à
voisins le bretonneux c'est le cas pour
les fermetures en revanche ainsi
fermeture dans le département si
fermeture de classe c'est le cas donc de
l'école de la quatrième classe pardon de
l'école maternelle jean de la fontaine à
elancourt collaboration renforcée à
l'étranger pour lui vs qu l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
un accord a été signé avec l'université
du colorado aux états unis objectif
principal renforcer la collaboration
entre le latmos le laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales et le l'asp son pendant
américain elle et de services font des
recherches similaires dans le domaine
le partenariat prévoit également un
programme d' échanges entre les
étudiants et un travail commun autour
des formations aux technologies
spatiales à maurepas une nouvelle vie
pour le local de l'ancienne librairie il
va bientôt rouvrir pour accueillir une
cave à vin à la base du projet un joli
minois diplômés d'oenologie
la vente de journaux sera aussi
préserver l et précision avec ce
reportage d'yves up stand berger et
nicolas kirilow nice dans dix jours les
étagères seront remplis de produits du
terroir la poussière aura disparu et
hugo roux 23 ans diplômé de l'école du
vin à paris pourra partager sa passion
et présenté 150 à 200 références de vins
aux morts passe bien là l'avantagé
d'avoir un bar et de pouvoir être au
contact de ma clientèle tous les jours
c'est de pouvoir discuter avec les
clients les conseiller sur des vins pas
forcément que français car vous verrez
qu'on aura une gamme assez étranger et
sur des vins étrangers des spiritueux de
tout le monde et on va pouvoir vraiment
la chercher le conseil client et à
pouvoir aiguiller le client au maximum
associé avec son père le jeune homme
proposera également à la dégustation des
spiritueux et des planches de fromages
et de charcuteries installé dans les
locaux de l'ancienne librairie fermé il
ya un an la nouvelle cave à vin a pour
objectif aussi de redonner vie au
quartier
un espace dédié à la presse est ainsi
conservée pour répondre aux attentes de
la population locale l'objectif il est
simple c'est de dire aux personnes qui
viennent prendre leur presse de pouvoir
venir partager un moment est de pouvoir
se retrouver autour d'un verre de vin ou
une planche arrêté et pas que d'aller
acheter son journal
situé en plein coeur du centre-ville de
maurepas le coin du sommelier ouvrira
ses portes le 14 2 septembre prochain
pour une inauguration avec modération
hier vous avez suivi dans notre journal
la rentrée scolaire dans les yvelines
mais il n'y a bien sûr pas que les
jeunes qui retournent en classe les
députés eux font leur entrée à
parlementaire le 25 septembre prochain
session extraordinaire à l'assemblée
nationale et ce sera une première pour
onze députés yvelinois de la république
en marche chez lui en juin dernier avec
nous sur ce plateau nous a rejoint
didier baichère bonsoir messieurs vous
êtes député lrm de la première
circonscription des yvelines elle
comprend je le rappelle une partie de
versailles les villes de guyancourt et
de montigny le bretonneux
alors avant de parler de votre rentrée à
vous un mot sur l'actualité et les
annonces au faite aujourd'hui par le
premier ministre edouard philippe
edouard philippe pardon à retenir
principalement la fin du rsi le régime
social des années
donc il sera rattaché à partir du 1er
janvier 2018 au régime général de la
sécurité sociale c'est une mesure
évidente à mettre en place
c'est un engagement fort du gouvernement
enfin en tout en tout cas du candidat
emmanuel macron président et donc du
gouvernement et c'est important de le
mettre en place rapidement puisque cette
mesure sera applicable à partir du 1er
janvier 2018 donc avec une phase de
transition pense que beaucoup
d'indépendants et d'entrepreneurs avait
subi le rsi depuis 2006 et sont ravis de
cette décision il ya quelques autres
mesures donc je ne sais pas peut-être
qu'on y reviendra mais dans la foulée
pour les entrepreneurs qui ont été moins
été annoncée tard beaucoup d'entrain
d'entrepreneurs ça concerne
effectivement 6,6 millions de français
qui exercent des professions libérales
donc on intègre les commerçants et les
entrepreneurs qui auront pour ce qui
crée une activité en 2018 auront une
année blanche de cotisations de sécurité
sociale jusqu'à 40000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires donc ça aussi c'est une très
bonne nouvelle pour l'emploi parce que
qui dit entrepreneurs nouvelle
entreprise dit développement de l'emploi
ça c'est essentiel
alors autre question bien sûr qui fait
l'actualité la présentation des
ordonnances sur la loi travail on va pas
revenir sur le contenu de ces
ordonnances jeu je renvoie mais les
téléspectateurs à notre émission 7,8
l'hebdo de la semaine dernière en tout
cas sur cette horde sur cette
présentation des ordonnances il ya
l'appel à manifestations de la cgt qui
est donc appel à la grève le 12
septembre
est ce que vous voyez vous comprenez
qu'il ya des oppositions finalement face
à ce texte à ces ordonnances de la loi
travail un wiki et les oppositions bien
sûr je le comprends maintenant il ya de
la méthode et de la concertation c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi que la cgt est
isolé dans cette manifestation du 2
septembre
il ya eu 46 des réunions pour été menée
en six semaines pendant l'été et je
pense que beaucoup d'organisations
syndicales qui ont été consultés les
organisations syndicales représentatives
bien sûr
hulu est en tout cas le travail qui a
été fait par le premier ministre et par
muriel pénicaud la ministre du travail
on verra le 12 je pense qu à de la
pédagogie à faire et moi je renvoie en
tout cas les téléspectateurs qu'ils
veulent qu'ils veulent voir le détail
des 36 mesure parce qu'on va vite
souvent à quelques mesures mais il ya 36
mesures en faveur des tpe et des pme qui
sont détaillées sur sur mon site didier
baichère point fr donc ils peuvent aller
regarder le détail et débattre avec moi
à travers mon site internet s'ils le
souhaitent sur sur ces mesures
justement qu'est ce que vous avez envie
de dire à ces organisations syndicales
je pense à la halle à la cgt qui s'est
finalement ces ordonnances ou et vous
l'a dit ça a été le fruit d'un long
travail ça a été réfléchie oui c'est le
fruit de la concertation et c'est
surtout le fruit de la réalité du
dialogue social tel qu'on le voit dans
les entreprises aujourd'hui 90 % de nos
entreprises sont des tpe et des pme qui
n'étaient pas représentés souvent dans
le dialogue social puisque c'étaient les
branches et les grandes entreprises
souvent qui avait le monopole de la
négociation sociale dans les entreprises
enfin en tout cas dans les branches et
là enfin pour une fois depuis des années
des dizaines d'années on remet du
dialogue social pensée pour 90 % de nos
entreprises
90% des entreprises qui représentent 50
% des salariés français
une délégation unique du personnel donc
une vraie concertation le chef
d'entreprise aura en face de lui une
délégation du personnel unique donc on
n'aura plus le chat et la souris entre
les différentes instances
on parle de quelque chose en cee puis
appréhendé paix on évite de se répondre
dans une seule instance
donc on remet le dialogue social au
coeur de la discussion de l'entreprise
c'est essentiel alors didier baichère
vous avez été élu pour la première fois
du coup en juin dernier au poste de
député de la première circonscription
il ya plusieurs choses qui ont été
votées durant l'été juste avant les
vacances on va pas faire un inventaire a
bien sûr parce que ça serait peut-être
un peu trop lourd si vous avez envie oui
vous vous de mettre en avant une mesure
phare qui a été voté avant les vacances
ou penser à laquelle l'engagement qu'on
avait pris sur le retour à la confiance
dans la vie publique
on a débattu énormément sur ce sujet est
très concrètement c'est désormais
l'interdiction des emplois familiaux
pour les parlementaires
ce qui peut sembler une évidence pour
les gens qui nous écoutent mais n'ont
jusqu'à maintenant souvent des familles
entières étaient embauchés
à part les hommes politiques donc ça
s'est terminé l'arrêt de la réserve
parlementaire qui était distribué un peu
de manière à dire opaque
en tout cas pas avec des règles très
très claires donc ça pareil c'est
terminé et puis le j'ai envie de dire la
transparence qu'on met sur les
indemnités parlementaires qui sont
désormais soumises strictement à
justificatifs comme dans n'importe
quelle entreprise vous avez des frais
professionnels vous donner les
justificatifs on vous rembourse alors
qu'avant là aussi ça manquait de
transparence
c'était un engagement fort des manuels
macron ça y est c'est en place ça a été
votée avant le 9 août donc on va vite en
dernière chose dans cette interview je
les dis rentrée parlementaire le 25
septembre prochain comment vous
l'abordez cette première rentrée
parlementaire
on est déjà rentré depuis la semaine
dernière on fait donc oui c'est vrai que
c'est officiellement exceptionnel voilà
là soyez sûr sur les textes mais nous
notre rentrée elle et elle est déjà
opérationnel je pense qu'on est on est
concentrés moi vous savez ça fait déjà
une semaine je suis à faire la semaine
dernière avec les entreprises adhérentes
du medef 78 avec qui j'ai travaillé
les professeurs puisque j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir rencontrer des
professeurs pendant leur prérentrée à
versailles à montigny lycées écoles
primaires qui j'ai d'ailleurs proposé
pour les professeurs du lycée de se
rencontrer tous les trimestres parce que
souvenez vous on a on a beaucoup aussi
parlé de l'évaluation des politiques
publiques et je crois que le rôle du
député c'est non seulement d'être sur le
terrain mais c'est aussi d'aller
discuter avec les interlocuteurs et
qu'on puisse évaluer les mesures que
nous mettrons en place dont j'ai fait la
même proposition aux entreprises du 78
une fois par trimestre se rencontrer
pour évaluer et la manne jazz aux
greniers finale des professeurs pour les
mesures pour l'éducation et quels
principaux chantiers là pour pour les
prochains mois du coup moi j'ai un gros
chantier là qui démarre de travail sur
l'égalité des chances et l'égalité des
territoires
c'est quelque chose qui me tenait
beaucoup à coeur quand j'ai été drh et
là je trace je démarre un travail en
fait
or ce serait un peu long de rentrer dans
les emplois francs mais c'est comment en
fait on va aider les entreprises à
embaucher des jeunes qui sont issus de
quartiers dit
sensible difficile et s'assurer en fait
que ces jeunes vont bénéficier de la
bonne exposition de leurs compétences et
qu'on ne donne pas uniquement un
avantage fiscal aux entreprises mais en
tout cas qu'il sélectionne les bonnes
compétences dans les quartiers donc là
je suis en train de travailler et que
saïd hammouche de mouiller de mozaïk rh
qui a travaillé beaucoup ces dernières
années sur l'identification des
compétences de ces jeunes donc voilà on
est en train de phosphorer pour faire
des propositions d'amendements sur ce
sujet merci didier baichère bercy
rappelle député de la première
circonscription des yvelines bien sûr
sous l'étiquette de la république en
marche toute autre chose maintenant un
événement international le week-end
dernier à elancourt la coupe du monde de
saut goûter aux s'est tenue au palais
des sports plus de 200 joueurs venus des
cinq continents étaient de la partie
alors vous avez sans doute jamais
entendu parler du souk où théo c'est le
football de table inventé par l'anglais
peter adolphe retour sur la compétition
avec yves obstine berger et mélanie
poker
vingt-deux joueurs deux équipes un
ballon le match peut commencer
pour cette rencontre l'italie affronte
l'espagne ils jouent avec leurs doigts
bienvenue à la coupe du monde de
supputer au football de table le joueur
attaquant est celui qui touche le ballon
donc tant qu'il touche le ballon et
qu'il ne l'envoie pas ni à l'extérieur
du terrain ni sur un adversaire
il en conserve la possession à chaque
fois que l'attaquant touche le ballon
une fois le défenseur a la possibilité
de jouer ce qu'on appelle un coup de
défense pour freiner la progression de
l'attaquant mais ce coup de défense ne
doit rien toucher d'autres ni le ballon
ni en attaquant né une figurine
défenseur précision concentration jeu
défensif ou jeu d'attaquant 24 nations
se sont affrontées dans cette 24e
édition qui se jouait pour la première
fois à elancourt c'est la première fois
qu'on joue en france après plusieurs
années et l'encours est une belle ville
l'an passé c'était une belle compétition
aussi mais cette année les organisateurs
ont fait encore mieux ce soit en france
et c'est bien et ça développe aussi le
football de table français qui est pas
très connu par rapport à d'autres pays
comme l'italie ou la belgique
dix mille pratiquants sont aujourd'hui
classés mondialement le pays le mieux
représenté c'est l'italie avait plus de
1000 joueurs et côté résultats sachez
que l'italie a glané sept médailles dans
cette compétition le compte à rebours
est lancé la ryder cup 2018 c'est dans
un an à guyancourt pour faire découvrir
le sport au plus grand nombre
la fédération française de la discipline
s'est associé à des centaines de golf en
france
le but proposer des initiations
gratuites
un partenariat a notamment été créés
cette année avec le gloss le golf blue
green de saint quentin en yvelines ni
thales ni d'euros apprendre à swinguer
en deux heures c'est la promesse du
golfe le saint quentin en yvelines la
structure propose jusqu'à fin septembre
des initiations gratuites en partenariat
avec la fédération française avec ces
baptêmes la structure espère casser les
préjugés quand les gens ne connaissent
pas du tout ils disent que c'est un
sport on va dire entre guillemets de
vieux que ce n'est pas un sport déjà
pour certains et
qui sont vraiment je dirais agréablement
surpris par ce qu'ils découvrent
lorsqu'ils font l'initiation
après un premier briefing d'une dizaine
de minutes les golfeurs en herbe
répartis en groupes de huit personnes
adultes et enfants sur lancers club à la
main dans le grand bain sous les
conseils d'un professeur un débutant se
pose plein de questions dix mille
questions c'est pour ça on essaie d'être
le plus simple possible
on essaye au maximum de ne pas pas
technique de parler vous avez vu j'ai
parlé de lancer ces faut faire simple le
plus sain possible c'est à dire les gens
disent ni la tête ni cogez tiko jti
cogit et a pu alors qu'il faut taper il
faut jouer il faut swing et libéré après
une heure d'initiation premier verdict
le plus difficile c'est vraiment le
mouvement naturel parce que quand on
quand on quand on est avec le club et
quand on est avec la balle on a tendance
à vouloir forcer
alors que non faut pas forcer donc c'est
voilà c'est trouver le mouvement naturel
du golfe
alors moi je préfère le green les
mouvements douceur le petit balancier en
douceur parce que c'est vrai que le
swing c'est pas facile moi je me plante
dans le dans le sol au départ voilà donc
j'ai à progresser je crois à la fin de
la session entre 25 et 30% des golfeurs
débutants passe le pas et décide de
s'inscrire et débourserons entre 750 et
1000 euros pour une année le prix pour
devenir peut-être un jour le futur tiger
woods un français sur dix ans serait
accro aujourd'hui la couture souvent
pratiqué par nos grands mères à revient
à la mode dans la ville de maurepas une
jeune maman de 34 ans n'a pas hésité à
ressortir les aiguilles et sa machine à
coudre pour confectionner elle même ses
vêtements ce qui lui a valu d'être
sélectionné dans une émission à télé
ademe six reportages de mickaël landreau
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans mon
atelier
cet atelier c'est le monde dan charlotte
ouest est l'une maurepas viennent de 34
ans depuis 2013 s'est lancé dans la
couture sous les conseils de sa maman
elle-même couturière j'ai quand même
toujours et emmanuel chassé manuel de
manière globale mais pour moi je sais
pas la couture ça restait quelque chose
d'inaccessible je voyais
voilà mais sur coup deux je me disais
mais je peux pas je n'arriverai jamais
quoi comme quoi je pense que voilà on
peut tout ceci m c'est vraiment
accessible à tous aujourd'hui cette
jeune maman essaie de coudre tous les
jours ou presque en jongle entre sa vie
de famille et son travail d'assistante
sociale
sa passion lui permet de confectionner
un à deux vêtements par semaine grâce à
des tissus acheté sur internet ou aux
marchés d'autres je voulais un trench
jaune voilà et je me suis dit
j'achèterai pas parce que je ne
trouverai pas la couleur qui me faut et
voilà j'ai trouvé ce tissu un petit peu
jaune orangé avec une jolie doublure en
twill de soie et voilà et je les adore
tout simplement c'est coloré c'est
pêchue et et puis c'est tendance parce
que je pense que je connais c'est à la
mode
voilà pour faire vivre ses aventures et
partager ses créations elle a décidé de
créer un blog baptisé le bazar d'anne
charlotte et de publier en moyenne
quatre à cinq articles par mois
la couturière enregistre sur la
plateforme environ 1000 visites par
semaine
je sais à quel point ça peut être utile
quand les filles me disent ah super
grâce à toi j'ai compris comment réussir
le vêtement
voilà comment aussi taillé tailler grand
taille petit ce qui va ce qui va pas
quelques ici tu me conseilles donc je
pense que oui le mon blog peut être un
support dead comme moi je me serve aussi
d autres blogs au final quoi au delà de
son blog
anne-charlotte défend sa passion à la
télévision candidate de l'émission cousu
main concours de couturiers amateurs à
mort d'asia n'a été retenu par m6 parmi
plus de 3000 personnes
j'ai même challenge je suis très bonne
je suis une très belle joueuse moi c'est
à dire que je me suis dis bah voilà
peu importe si je reste jusqu'au bout ou
pas
j'ai envie de m'éclater et je me suis
éclaté après cette expérience retour à
la vie normale dans son atelier de
maurepas prochain challenge pour la
couturière transmettre le virus du
tricot et du point de croix à ses
enfants une dernière info avant de se
quitter elle réjouira sans doute les
fans de titeuf zep sera au pôle culturel
de la lanterne à rambouillet vendredi
soir à partir de 20 heures
le créateur du célèbre garçon à la mèche
blonde et auteur de plusieurs autres
bandes dessinées répondra à vos
questions le tout en dessins projetés
sur grand écran
pour rappel l'album numéro 15 des
aventures de titeuf à fond le slip vient
de sortir en librairie est la rencontre
de vendredi est gratuite sur réservation
c'est la fin de ce journal sur tv 78
tous nos reportages à retrouver sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]